okay so the question is can that sense
of meaning behind you and the answer to
that is absolutely absolutely because
you could say that the ultimate sense of
meaning is composed of the union of
fragmentary senses of meaning and the
fragmentary sensitive meaning can be
overwhelmingly powerful anger sexual
lust and and and the sorts of things
that you experience wouldn't say when
you're playing a video game which are
very carefully calibrated to keep you on
the on the edge of exploration let's say
now I'm not a full of video games
because games are complicated and it
isn't clear what people are doing when
they're playing them you know they may
be expanding their cognitive skills they
may be learning to cooperate they may be
learning to engage in complex
problem-solving and so but part of it's
also a matter of balance you know fifty
hours a week probably not unless you're
going to go pro right because there's
other things you need to be attending to
it's not a stable solution for you your
family your society it's too one-sided
yeah and you can get pulled down rabbit
holes of all sorts that that are
one-sided pursuits of meaning so and
some something we're actually going to
talk about as the later class is unfold
the question is how do you stop yourself
from falling prey to a pathologist sense
of meaning and I think one of the
answers to that is don't lie because
what you're hoping is that your nervous
system is sufficiently healthy and well
programmed so that what it reads out to
you is reliable and if you pathologize
your psyche by either through sins of
omission let's say or outright deception
you're going to work that internal
structure and it's not going to read out
properly to you and then your sense of
meaning will leave you astray so like
one of the reasons for speaking the
truth I shouldn't say that because you
don't know how to speak the truth but
you do know how not to lie and it's a
game you're playing with yourself you
can define the damn lies no one else has
to do that for you you you try not to
utter falsehoods because you warp your
neurological structure by doing so and
then it will read out pathologically and
then if you rely on it to guide you
we'll run you right off a cliff so
that's why there's a moral element to
this is if you're going to rely on your
sense of meaning make sure that you
don't pollute the mechanism see this is
this is partly why people go to
confession right which is mud which is
like ascetic psychotherapeutic technique
it's like okay what's stupid miserable
wretched things did I do this week
that's a good thing to to make conscious
right because maybe you cannot do them
the next week and you think well why did
would you bother it's like well you're
in a ship it's sailing across the stormy
seas if you're if you're hacking holes
in it with a pickaxe you should probably
pay attention to that before you sink so
it's a good idea to keep to keep what
you're doing that's stupid in mind so
that you can stop doing it and so then
you can more and more rely on yourself
and your and your own you know your own
conscience let's say as a guide to
proper action you know in the Pinocchio
story is that the conscience was not an
unerring guide for Pinocchio it had to
learn and so and so it's also partly
pushing yourself into new situations and
differentiating yourself so that you get
wiser and and so it's courage as well as
truth notice those might be the -
there's more Beauty courage truth you
know the fundamental virtues yeah why be
virtuous that's the question and so that
you can bear the suffering of life
without becoming corrupt right it's
practical it's practical if there's
nothing more practical than that so
unless you want misery and people do you
know it's exciting misery so other
questions
alright then see you next Wednesday